what was the first crime you committed
the first mortgage I ever did a mortgage
is me borrowing money from a bank to buy
a house yeah how can you find a way to
commit crime in this how can you do
fraud in this space it's it's very
difficult for the average guy to commit
fraud because there's so many safeguards
set up um you know if you were to go in
and say um make $300,000 a year okay
well we want your W2s we want your pay
stuffs we're going to call your employer
we're going to check to make sure your
employer how long they've been in
corporated we're going to check to make
sure they're registered we're it's like
ah your whole plan fell apart you know
because the average guy can't do that he
can't even come up with the with the pce
W2 so the average person you know or I'm
going to put down this much money but
you're going to borrow that money from
the seller you know okay well then they
start asking for bank statements where
did the money come from how long long
has it been in your bank like you can't
even have it put in your bank for a day
get a letter you know it's got to have
been there for 90 days or 60 days
depending on the bank and and so there's
all these ways for the average person
it's very difficult to commit fraud the
average guy that works at Walmart and
makes $6,000 a year and he's been there
for 5 years and he saved his deposit
like it's a very that's really the guy
that those transactions are set up for
to borrow a mortgage from Bank of
America that's the guy they're looking
for so to commit fraud in this space had
to misrepresent some aspect of your
identity of how much you're worth how
much money you have this kind of stuff
right you have to be able to to lie to
the bank anytime you lie to the bank
you've committed fraud and it's funny
when I was you know doing it I would say
ah it's it's in the gray area there's no
gray area you're either lying in some
capacity or you're not
so it's for instance the very first loan
I did I I wided out um my borrower had
been 30 days late on her uh on her rent
so they're really looking at the last
two years so when when you go into the
bank and they most of what they're
asking is a is a two-year window they're
saying how long have you been on their
job they care about two years and how
long have you been at your um at your
residency they're looking for two years
now you could be at three places in two
years that's fine as long as you
consistent consistently paid for two
years well she had been in an apartment
complex but she'd been 30 days late now
she caught it up but she was late Bank
you the bank doesn't want to lend you
money if if you've been 30 days late so
I was a broker and I Whited out the
30-day late I just got rid of it and my
manager is the person that told me to do
it she said it'll be fine and she was
right it was what did it feel like so
that was the first fraudulent action you
committed
yeah I I
mean I you know I I was I was worried
you know I always say you know I sweated
bullets for you know four or five days
you know but I mean I I I was concerned
and and I don't know that I was
concerned that I had broken the
law uh I was concerned because I was
behind on my on my truck payment I was
behind on my mortgage like I had banked
on being a mortgage broker and I'd go
deep deep behind on all my bills to do
this so in the last minute when this
loan isn't going to close and I have to
commit fraud to make that happen and the
idea my fear was they were going to
figure it out and maybe I'd get fired
you know I didn't think I was going to
go to jail because my manager assured me
you're not going to jail like they'll
you'll get fired at at
best so my concern was they were going
to catch it and I get fired and I
wouldn't get paid like I needed that
money so bad
so maybe paint the picture here where
were you working who was the manager the
manager what it's funny because I I I
don't think I ever really mentioned this
it her name was uh Gretchen Zas she
eventually I don't mind saying she
eventually got ended up going to jail
for fraud her name was gret and Zas and
she was a manager I was working for a
company called Eagle lending and it was
in
Tampa and I this was like my first month
so my very first deal three or four
weeks into it into that first month and
I walk in I put the file in front of my
manager she looks through everything you
know oh great good good and put this one
piece of paper over here MH and sat
there and then when she was done I said
uh what's what's going on she goes
perfect files perfect she goes but your
borrow was 30-day late on her rent and
she says that that's it's done she's
like that's a deal killer and I was like
oh my gosh you know what do I do and I
remember she pulled out a w thing a
white out remember the white out not the
sticks but the one and she started going
and I was like what she go if I was you
and she handed she said I'd wi it out
make a copy stick it back in the file
yeah she said it'll be fine and I went I
could I was like that that's fraud I
could go to jail and she goes and she
was like it's they're never going to
catch it she said look we do stuff I do
stuff all the time she said they're not
going to catch it and nobody's calling
the FBI she was the worst case that that
worst case scenario if underwriting
catches
it then they'll fire you that's it
nobody's calling you're not going to
jail and I was you know I trusted her I
was like
okay and so I I did what she said I
stuck it in the file and I mean look
like I said for four or five days I was
like oh my God I'm so scared how old do
you at this point probably 29 I think it
was 29 you know like I had gone to
college and so many things had not
worked out you know I got a degree in
Fine Arts it's not it's not a uh there's
not a lot of people looking for anyone
with a fine arts degree and uh you know
I tried my I tried to be
a uh tried to be a an insurance adjuster
tried that for about a year year and a
half that didn't work out uh ended up
ended up working
construction for a few
years and you know so finally the girl I
was dating said you got to be a mortgage
broker you know she's just had just
started as a Mortgage in the mortgage
industry and she was like you have to do
this like you were born to do this this
is perfect for you what did she see in
you she said just you're salesman and I
was like cuz I was like you know I
barely balanced my checkbook like I
don't I don't know anything about
numbers and she was like it has nothing
to do with that it's sales it's putting
together deals you know you're good at
that you're good at negotiating you're
you know you're a national sales
salesman and I figured i' I need to try
something so what aspect of more
mortgage is is sales and deal making and
what aspects require the Charisma that
you clearly have well one you've got you
have clients that have lots of options
they can go to Bank of America they can
go to Sun Trust they can go to Chase
they have options if they have perfect
credit I ended up working for a company
that was a subprime lender and those
people didn't have a lot of options by
Honestly by the time they got to that to
Eagle lending their options were over so
what ended up ends up happening is
you're negotiating with
sellers you know you would think that a
lot of the stuff that in that industry
that real estate
agents should do you the Brokers end up
doing because real estate agents are are
used to you meet them at the house or
they take you to several houses they you
know they they open the door they walk
around they write up a contract that's
legit a legit contract and you already
you're already
pre-approved everything works out but
subprime that's not the case you got
borrowers with horrific job history they
don't have enough of the down payment
they can't maybe they have the down
payment but they don't have the closing
cost so you have to go to the real
estate agent and say listen I need you
to raise the purchase price and have the
the seller pay the closing costs which
is legal but that's not to a degree but
that's not how they wrote up the
contract so now you're having to get
them to rewrite the contract or you're
have you're you know there's little
things you're trying to do and the more
the more deals you get done and the more
you deal with certain real estate agents
the more you start to
realize that they're you know you know
which ones are completely above board
and which ones are willing to twist the
rules and a lot of it works on personal
relationships right right for some
reason people tend to like me and trust
me yeah I don't know why it's it's it
hasn't worked out for so many people but
people naturally seem to trust me and so
if I say hey I can close the loan but
you got to do this it'll be cool don't
worry we do it all the time it's like my
third loan and you know I I've been
doing this for years and they go okay
and then they raise the purchase price
they add some money they have the seller
of the house give the borrower some
money they stick it in the bank or they
put it in the in escrow at the closing
company like now you're starting to
massage deals what was the second time
you committed a crime so what how did it
start to evolve from the white out well
I mean when that went through you know
I I think a normal person probably would
have
said wow it was a onetime thing got away
with it I'm good but for me it just
emboldened me mhm like I just got a
check for like I don't know what it was
$ 25 $3500 I was thrilled and by that
time I was already working on another
deal but that
guy he made I forget something like he
had made like let's say
$45,000 the year before in his
W2 if you based on his based on his
current track record or or his year-to
date of his pay stub he made just enough
money but if you factored in last year's
W2 he was shy so if I Chang that 45,000
to
51,000 then he could the loan closes I
get a check for 3500 bucks he gets into
a house I'm doing him a favor you know
I'm doing God's work so I fix it it I
kick back I'm terrified a little bit you
know worried about it sure enough it
closes four or five days later they call
me he's ready to close a week later we
close I get a check next guy that comes
in I mean I got very very quick
I was concerned do you have a house do
you have a deal is it ready I can get
you I can get you done now if you were
in bankruptcy or something there's some
things you just they You' pull their
credit and you just couldn't help them
if they were if they had a 550 credit
score or something and no job I mean you
know it had to be within reason but very
quickly it was changing W2s changing pay
subs changing appraisals um you know
fixing verif like I said verifications
of
rent so it evolved very quickly for me
and you're essentially helping people
that's what I told myself giving them a
chance people that have been really
struggling financially in life so you've
been telling yourself that this is
you're doing a good good thing for
people I told myself that right up until
that those loans were solid and I was
helping those people out right up until
I went to prison and and I was in prison
and I had to write
the government asked me to write an
ethics and fraud course for to help
teach the nation's mortgage
brokers um you know all loan officers
and Brokers have to take I think it's
nine hours of continuing education every
single year and I was approached to
write the ethics
course and it was about that time and
about the same period of time I was
writing uh writing a book my
book and that kind of used I started
reflecting on what I had done you know
and the truth is
like and this is a horrible thing to say
cuz the first time I ever heard somebody
say this I remember thinking oh that's a
horrible thing to say some people should
not own a house they shouldn't be
allowed to borrow they're not in a
position financially you know and and
there were there were many occasions
where I put someone in a house that they
100% swore they could afford it was I
was helping them I told myself I was
helping them and a year and a half later
they're going into foreclosure their
stuff's on the corner they don't know
where to
go and the truth is is that I I'm not
smarter than the actuaries that came up
with those underwriting
guidelines so in this whole process how
are you making money are you taking a
percentage broker fee yeah I charge a
broker fee or you charge yield spread so
yield spread is let's say the interest
rate is 8% interest if I charge them $25
basis points over the 8% so I charge
them 8 and a quar you know 8.25 then I
get 1% of the loan back as a fee so if I
charge them 8.5% I get two points back
so if it's a $100,000 piece of property
and the bank says your interest rate is
going to be 8% and I tell you
8.5 and I'm charging you a $3,500 broker
fee now I'm making
$5,500 so on even a $100,000 loan you
could make a nice chunk of change I mean
it's so how much gray area is here you
said that there really isn't when you're
lying or not but I mean you're feel like
there is it well every time I changed
something it wasn't gray area I just
committed I just committed fraud at this
level you're either you either meet the
guidelines or someone has massaged it in
such a way that they've committed fraud
that's it and there's now there's
there's tons of ways where you can
commit fraud
and they just can't figure it out does
that make sense like I I mean I've
you've committed fraud and it's like
they've look at the entire they look at
all the documents and they double check
everything and they know there's fraud
in here and they just can't find it just
because they can't find it doesn't mean
doesn't mean it was exactly doesn't mean
it wasn't
fraud